how's it going red I'm cut suck my name
is beer back welcome back to some more
Silencio god that's not correct god damn
it Nancy or losses anyway we need a
header with the done classroom oh man
you see it not the one next to me on the
others
all right caught let's go over that
ah Larry's [ __ ] you like oh no no no I
came so okay okay you can do this kids
shake him up good guess but Larry no one
[ __ ] likes here wait don't tell me
this is the I unlock this room didn't I
okay alright let's use the key here ah
stand the [ __ ] back oh [ __ ] no all right
I'm not gonna die today no don't die
don't die don't die don't die don't die
please whatever you do don't I don't I
don't I don't I'm [ __ ] up Larry today
yeah soon
check out this is how I roll wasting
ammo like a boss whatever I would bleach
don't worry like I have plenty ammo I
don't [ __ ] what ow I ran in the floor
unlock that just break it okay maybe I
can bypass I think it's only a penguin
okay do we need to think lapid's all
right what do we got
I'm stupid I'm not supposed to go here I
need to go over here please don't be
lies be gentle with me Larry oh thank
god Larry Craig appearing what you're
not supposed to say what look what you
made me do seriously I can't waste ammo
in this game I was not good
Oh No
hey V over here what's up all right and
now left cockroach [ __ ]
does anyone here like cockroaches I
think Larry's are nice they look like
tiny little breasts oh yeah okay they're
not that cute
all right let's keep going down I guess
this is quiet
way too quiet is this
which door should we take I don't like
any of this check the map store is your
boiler room let's go to storage
I've been in here why do I come shotgun
shells where's my shotgun oh there's
gotta be a boss fine I know it we should
go to the infirmary face
I'll cut okay I'll cut me going to the
infirmary I breast we gotta save alright
it's boss battle time I think at least
let's go down here
huh sup man I wish you'd give me the
[ __ ] shotgun it alright what's up its
to bowels I don't know if I should touch
them I think I have to
alright valve do it I can touch them
fine what what today what today it's a
pasta well this should work if I turn it
to the right
nope I just made it [ __ ] worse let's
do it again
stop listen your ass is about to be
missing pity solving puzzles like is
ain't nobody's business
alright keep telling them it's kind of
[ __ ] hard to see
there we go ah food if I the tedious
realize I do need if advisor junior to
deploy what why is it going down can it
go up instead that would be a lot nicer
oh [ __ ] what Wow
I was just looking for my daughter
iodized for any of this you know what is
this yeah it's at a John no it's it I
don't even know I'm out of here
come on pity you can do this it's just a
big [ __ ] rad kettle a rattler a
Rachel ragout hey [ __ ] Rajon don't scare
me right now don't make me kill you
that's right No Oh God
right to my deck seriously alright let
me kill you let me love all right how
about here [ __ ] off
I recollect electrode alert Oh
I wish I had the shotgun I think that
would help out a lot I shut drool all
over my new outfit oh I got his tail
almost
whoa he doesn't like that no sir
well [ __ ] you freaks me out what is your
problem
what is he doing
well that's my health how's my Abba I
don't have any left
god damn it
what do we do oh I got it I got it now
I'm supposed to wait wait for edge right
father
hey Jack man oh dude are you kidding me
I'm loading those good hell ah
why are you do it early hey tricked me
that [ __ ] thing all right I need to
find out where you get the shotgun all
right so I have not cheated but I think
we need to go to the bathrooms cuz we
never actually checked out the bathroom
not to think about it all right
yes and it might hours no I didn't think
so
all right let's check the bathroom
inside with the ladies hell out of the
girl sup girls you want to [ __ ] no well
me neither
Wow so this is how the ladies bathroom
go like have you ever heard about a
tampon huh it's not that difficult even
I am aware of them goddamn ladies with
their tampons
whoa no what in the heavens
very sexy oh hell it's raping yeah hey
girl what's up why would somebody let's
make out there you are oh thank Jesus
all right
yes I'll take you take you home and show
my mama yes it's my girlfriend she is
very founder in a bathrobe all right now
I literally can't wait what the [ __ ]
happens in the boys back all right let's
check that oh I know oh that's where we
came - check these doors the first thing
I did I'm an idiot all right what's up
well I guess we have period - son of a
[ __ ] maybe there were some ammo over
here no not on Yenta fina well fine I
don't give a [ __ ] goddamn it
hello disappoint good I think the girls
won that round actually all right I'm
stupid the thing is we need to run a lot
no and I don't like it because if I die
I have to redo a lot of [ __ ] so let's be
careful
most are kind of full of careful also
why the [ __ ] that I come from though
I thought I thought for sure where am I
where the hell did I come from like
seriously where the [ __ ] did I come from
hi Curtis
can I go through here yes I could
it's the game playing tricks on me right
now
I think this game is playing tricks on
me that's game seriously oh now there's
[ __ ] ammo here well thank you I
appreciate it but like what the [ __ ] did
the wall come from
why do you want from me a game I don't
appreciate this I don't know what to say
about this I really don't I didn't know
they have cages in bathrooms that is new
information for me
but seriously what what oh oh you think
you're funny game that was mine [ __ ] mm
what the hell no bad Larry's tweet
somebody went in the right direction
okay forward and then right
yeah Drakken that was so weird
really those so creepy okay we need to
run a lot actually again seriously once
you get used to all this running [ __ ]
around it's actually actually quite
enjoyable this I don't know it's hard to
put your finger on this game what do we
got we need to go to the infirmary
that's first priority all right Rose I'm
actually gonna end this here and in the
next episode we will hopefully kill the
boss I know how to kill it at least it
shouldn't be that difficult now that we
have the shotgun and we can rest
all right breast my support I convinced
you enjoyed subscribe akan my bread day
that's the next episode or ever I make
how do you bread my this is to do a gang
of selling get it over with
alright
here we are again much that the hell
into him gonna muster Oh son of a [ __ ]